et la protection des terres agricoles au
québec nicolas mas lite avec nous jette
journal et ce à grenoble vous êtes
derrière ce documentaire le bonsoir
bonsoir à vous alors on croyait certains
croyaient peut-être que depuis jean
garon à l'époque c'était réglé cette
histoire là on a une commission de
protection des terres agricoles au
québec pour un bon bain tout va bien on
peut dormir tranquille
c'est pas le col non écoutez il ya un
peu un vice de conception des départs si
on veut dans la loi de la protection du
territoire agricole il ya une loi qui
ont dit national l'international la
protection des terres agricoles mais ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
moteur le buldozer économique qui passe
sur nos terres nos terres agricoles le
carburant de sa 6e sont là ce sont les
taxes municipales c'est la fiscalité
municipale donc on a si vous voulez on a
une première couronne deuxième couronne
troisième couronne surtout dans la cmm
communauté métropolitaine de montréal où
vous avez des municipalités qui se
concurrencent en terrell pour pour des
projets immobiliers pour des parcs
industriels et vous avez aussi
avec le développement des routes des je
vous dirais des investisseurs
extrêmement patients qui sont embusqués
qui attendent jusqu'à la vo2 pas
finalement et à ce moment là ça ça crée
tout le temps je vous dirais il n'y a
pas meilleur presque pas meilleur
investissement qu une terre agricole
quand vous avez un boom immobilier
on va construire quand les maisons
coûtent trop cher on va construire
d'autres daumezon pour faire baisser les
prix mais quand on est dans les terres
agricoles c'est une ressource non
renouvelable
donc il ya quelque chose de très pervers
t'y attends au sens où aujourd'hui les
terres agricoles que tellement cher
parce que de la spéculation par pour de
nombreuses raisons surtout comme la dame
le dit dans le documentaire
l'agriculteur ya le choix de le vendre
si a pas de relève bay avant la groupie
pieds carrés
dans votre documentaire c'est très clair
c'est tellement rendu cher les terres
agricoles que c'est plus rentable de
faire dans plusieurs cas de
l'agriculture dessus et regarder si on
le prend au niveau économique on est pas
mal grandi dans un coude dans un
cul-de-sac au sens où quand
l'agriculteur là son principal outil
c'est la terre quand ils rendus en
particulier l'arrêt l'est la relève
agricole est pas capable de se payer des
prix pareils qui est contaminée par la
spéculation ou des gens qui sont
capables d'acheter des terres a plu au
prix d'une terre nourricière faut
distinguer ici la valeur agronomique
d'une terre la valeur agronomique c'est
ce que je suis capable de faire pousser
dessus un bon sol le taux
d'ensoleillement mais les gens la
différence de culture si vous voulez
c'est que les promoteurs vont l'avoir en
pieds carrés pour faire des entrepôts
pour faire des condos pour ce que vous
voulez tandis que l'autre l'agriculteur
il l'achète en hectare juste pour vos
auditeurs un état mettons ces trois
quarts d'un terrain de football où 17
terrains tennis pour les sportifs
vous êtes allé à laval vous êtes allé à
blainville vous attend sur la couronne
nord à mirabel
je donne un premier extrait à laval où
monsieur forget l'agriculteur le
producteur maraîcher vous explique qui
commence est encerclée de maisons que
les maisons ils veulent pas vivre à côté
les terres agricoles ac devenu c'est lui
qui est devenu l'étranger sur son seul
on écoute et on part faire le lit mais
dans la zone agricole dispose awad ahmed
bahi son lot
les premiers propriétaires étaient
conscients qu'ils avaient une ferme à
côté deux autres que ça change et ça
change et ça a changé lassé du monde qui
aime la campagne mais pas les
désagréments de convaincre la valeur
foncière va tellement augmenté et quand
tu achètes une maison de 250 à 400 ça
sert la marde
c'est plus fort simple ayo l'enclavement
ce qu'on vit c'est un peu comme le début
de la fin et ibo tisse autour de toi
pour t'isoler un coup et isolé c'est toi
qui devient la nuisance
combien on en a perdu de terres
agricoles depuis dix ans par exemple
depuis 10 ans ce qui est officiel on a
perdu environ d'après lui pôle et la
commission de la protection du
territoire agricole environ dix mille
hectares dix mille et en cessant ferme
moyenne au québec dans ce ténor on
continue à faire c'est et je vous repose
la question monsieur monsieur forget à
côté de lui pourquoi on a réussi à des
zones et des coins où il y avait de si
bonnes terres ben là le champignon vous
voyez l'étrange champignons de 40
maisons la société fait avant la loi de
la protection du territoire agricole
mais la pression s'exerce encore au bout
de sa terre on veut construire au nom de
la croissance démographique une station
multiples alors qu'il en existe une tout
près alors une autre on en rajoute une
autre qui va contaminer ses champs en
plus ce monsieur là il fait du sérieux
pour consommation humaine fait qu'à un
moment donné
les forget dont vous vous voyez dans le
documentaire ayons un surnom parce que
cdc on les appelle les gaulois de laval
c'est pas pour rien parce que tu
résistes tout le temps tu es tout le
temps en train de si vous voulez de vous
battre comme si tu avais pas assez de
produire le meilleur sur david
l'environnement oui dans votre
documentaire ce qui est fascinant c'est
vous appelez à toutes sortes de
pancartes ornées sur l'a15 on va dans
nord il ya des pancartes avant dans
pieds carrés que vous appelez vous fait
passer pour quelqu'un qui est intéressé
puis on vous dit bon lot 6 journées
agricoles mais si vous êtes patient ça
va être des zones est et ça va valoir
vingt fois de plus
exactement alors là comme si on vous
parlait de la commission de la
protection du territoire agricole ils
font leur possible
mais quand vous avez une terre enclavée
non seulement vous avez une terre
enclavée qui va difficile à cultiver
mais c'est parce qu'il ya de moins en
moins d'agriculteurs qui va aller
s'installer le puits qui peut la payer
alors les municipalités ont même pas
d'outil si vous voulez pour acheter à ce
prix là qu'elle était qui sont vendus
l'autre le l'autre versailles puis
voulait on le voit dans le documentaire
la mairesse l'ancienne mairesse de
boisbriand va l'écouter vous dites oui
mais monsieur mesli ça fait 40 ans dans
certains cas il ya un projet important
domiciliaire à boisbriand et la mairesse
vous dit on cultive plus l'eau depuis 50
ans les côtes
[Musique]
arrivées des super projet d' 100 200
hectares se pose est le projet
écologique avec l'agriculture intégrée
dans le projet et d'alphonse et
l'assainissement des maisons il est déjà
plein qui
vont suffire autres sur un projet
pascal boisbriand le projet on l'a
beaucoup
arrangé un peu verts ont dit va avoir
des jardins il va avoir des soucis d
cela mais je vous pose la question que
la mairesse vous pauvres s'ils ont le
culte si on les cultive poster là
pourquoi pas en faire des maisons il ya
des gens qui veulent y habiter
on perd une autre partie agricole dans
le fond ce projet-là quartier forestière
c'est qu'on voulait on fait passer de
l'agriculture urbaine dans un projet
domiciliaire
combien de temps ça peut durer avant
qu'on construise d'autres choses dessus
donc on des zones une zone agricole pour
faire ce qu au design de l'agriculture
urbaine je trouve que lon une certaine
malhonnêteté si vous gardez ces terres
là et que vous avez de jeunes
agriculteurs qu'ils puissent s'y établir
à condition que le prix serait
raisonnable quand je vous parlais
d'outils madame cordato auger demande et
de prix leur a convié ça se vende
esterle à 30 40 millions qui me disait
coûté qui peut s'acheter sa voix là
alors c'est je le répète j'ai fait un
travail fascinant parce que dans le
débat actuel sur davantage
d'indépendance alimentaire on a
l'impression que dans la réalité on va
pas du tout vers ça on continue à
développer des condos
favoriser l'étalement urbain elle est où
la solution en terminant monsieur
médecine je vous dirais que la solution
c'est
ça prend ça vient d'en haut ça prend un
peu un point sur la table c'est à dire
de créer peut-être une zone verte mais
immuable on n'a plus à s'en inquiéter
pendables immuable bathyscaphe un peu la
ville de toronto et je vous dirais même
vancouver et même ottawa jusqu'à un
certain point donc on à s'inspirer nous
québécois de ce qui se passe ainsi par
ailleurs j'encourage les gens
regardaient ça québec terre d'asfa nous
avait des gens intéressants à entendre
des producteurs maraîchers il ya une
productrice laitière également il ya des
gens dont qui ont une longue expérience
à laval sur la rive nord de montréal
merci monsieur mesli c'est à 20h ce soir
mesdames et messieurs à rdi merci de
nous avoir pas merci à vous bonne soirée